hello hello everybody and welcome to my
livestream how are you guys happy
international cat day my name is Hannah
Shaw and I am I am known as kitten lady
I am a professional animal rescuer and
I'm a humane educator I specialize in
saving the lives of the tiniest and most
vulnerable felines I am so happy to be
joined by all of you guys today on
international cat day what a great day
to be celebrating these little teeny
guys right here so this is gonna be
really fun
we will spend some time together I'll
answer some of your questions about
feline advocacy I'm gonna do a bottle
feeding with these little babies and
what I would love to do with you guys
today is to help name them because these
two kittens just came in to the animal
shelter Here I am actually on my book
tour right now I wrote a book called
tiny but mighty kitten lady's guide to
saving the most vulnerable feline this
is a book all about rescuing little
orphaned kittens like these guys and I'm
actually celebrating the launch of my
book right now I'm in Baltimore and I'm
working with barks Animal Shelter oh my
gosh you're ready to eat huh
so what we're gonna do and we just got
these two little babies in I'm gonna do
a feeding with them so you guys can
learn all about taking care of these
little teeny tiny guys and then I'll
answer your questions about taking care
of baby kittens and if you have any
great name ideas for these two let's
throw some of those name ideas into the
chat I see some great ideas coming in
sprinkle and sparkle I like your ideas
keep those ideas coming folks and so
like I said my name is Hannah I run a
YouTube channel also called kitten lady
where you can learn all of these skills
but this kitten is ready to eat
check this out she's actually trying to
nurse on my hand so why don't we do a
quick feeding with her and I'll tell you
everything you need to know about how to
do this stuff so these guys are or
and orphaned kittens or kittens who have
been separated from their mothers and
these babies when they come into an
animal shelter they're really highly at
risk unless there is a foster parent who
can help them out so I'm a big advocate
for fostering little kittens because
foster homes really do save lives when
you sign up to foster you are
responsible for basically kitten
babysitting you're taking care of them
for a couple of weeks getting them from
a period of being very very vulnerable
like this to a period of being able to
be adopted this little one right here
she is just about three three-and-a-half
weeks old you can feel her little teeth
starting to come in and so she is hungry
and ready to eat and she'll be ready to
be adopted at eight weeks so have you
ever fostered before tell me in the
comments if you have right now what I'm
gonna do I'm going to show you a kitten
care routine so you kind of know how
this works so the first thing we're
gonna do with our little kitten when we
are ready to do our orphan kitten care
routine is we're gonna help her go to
the bathroom and the way I'm gonna do
that is by stimulating her using some
tissues the reason that I do this is
that mom cat will actually lick her
young to help them go to the bathroom so
you know when you're taking care of a
foster kitten you're going to gently rub
the area down here around their little
butt so you can help them go potty and
they'll just go pee right into that soft
tissue and that will she's like I don't
need to go potty I need to eat some food
so once they've gone potty so she went
pee and then now we're going to give her
some food she is super ready to eat so
couple tips about bottle feeding
orphaned kittens you want to always feed
them in a natural belly down position so
think how they would eat from mom they
would you know walk up to her or kind of
you know go up to her like on their
belly and their belly would be down and
then they would nurse for Mom so we're
gonna keep their belly down we're going
to invert the bottle you can see she is
ready to go and maybe I can bring her a
little closer to you so you can actually
see her eating
and and we never want to like forcefully
squeeze a bottle with these little guys
we want them to suckle at their own pace
sometimes you'll see like she's really
excited so she's trying to stand up and
that's okay as long as her belly is
still down sometimes they want to hold
hands with you or hold on to the bottle
and that's all good too as long as the
belly is always facing downward when you
feed a kitten on their back they can
aspirate that's when the fluid goes into
their lungs and we don't want to do that
so we're just gonna give her a nice big
meal good job she's very very hungry so
this is what it looks like when you're
fostering kittens you can get all of the
you know amazing joy and feelings of
real triumph watching these kittens
transform before your eyes you know they
come in there they're so young and
vulnerable and you can you know give
them the food that they need and the
care that they need to be able to make
it to adoption age and it's such an
incredible gift I tell you everything
you need to know about foster care in my
new book it's called tiny but mighty and
it's got everything in here everything
from you know feeding to you know how to
give a kid in a bath how to find an
adopter even how to take care of
yourself when you're doing the work of
fostering kittens because the truth is
you know when you're fostering you have
to put your own self-care on the to-do
list as well so let's see if you want
any more food did you have a big meal or
are you happy just like listen I'll
always eat seconds I'm the same way I
totally get it something that you might
not know about these little kittens is
that the majority of kittens are
actually born outside on the streets in
the United States
80% of kittens who are born every year
are born to community cats who live
outside so they're not necessarily born
you know in people's homes they are born
outdoors and then people find them all
the time most kittens that come to me
you know they're found in the craziest
places like you know underneath porches
and in alleys and even under dumpsters
and stuff like that and these kittens
are found outside a lot of people assume
that they you know have been
abandoned but actually most of the time
these kittens are born to cats who live
outside there's a lot of cats who live
in our neighborhoods and they're called
community cats community cats you know
they live in the neighborhood these are
unknown cats and even though these are
cats who you know are not our pet cats
we still really have a duty to protect
these cats too and have sterilization
programs for them so we don't have so
many of these kittens being born because
honestly this time of year it's kitten
season and there are so many kittens
pouring into animal shelters here we
certainly don't need to be creating more
of them whether that's you know through
an intentionally breeding or through you
know cats being born outside so I'm a
big supporter of Trap Neuter Return
programs this is where you take the cats
who are living outdoors and you make
sure that they're all sterilized so that
there's not more population growth it's
so essential because these kids they're
coming into shelters and boxes and
buckets and bins you wouldn't believe
how many of these kittens are coming
into shelters every year and they need
our help
okay so we're gonna do a little care
routine with this one you guys already
know the drill now so we're gonna help
her go potty I know it's a little
embarrassing to go potty in front of all
of these friends but that's okay that's
okay so I'll look at some of the
questions and let's see how do I
convince my parents to let me foster
well I think it's awesome that you are
interested in fostering I think a great
thing that you could do is talk to your
family about maybe fostering in the
summer if you are you know still in
school a great thing that you could do
is you know while you are off in the
summer maybe you could foster a mom and
babies so even if you can't do you know
little orphan kittens like this maybe
get go baby
even if you can't do a little orphan
kittens like this you can always take
care of a mom and babies and when you
care for a mom and her babies then you
are able to actually you know just take
care of mom mom takes care of babies and
then you get all of the joy of taking
care of baby kittens without all of the
workers
you know waking up in the middle of the
night and bottle-feeding I think that's
a great thing for families to do
especially you know because kitten
season is in the summer when kids are
off from school and let's see if we have
any other comments we have Thank You
NatGeo for having Hannah on awesome
thanks Debbie yeah if you guys have not
watched my videos I have a lot of videos
on YouTube about kitten care you can
actually find me in the caption
underneath this video you can find links
to all of my stuff there but if you just
look up kitten lady on youtube you'll
find all of my information on there how
to do this stuff really the biggest
message I have for you guys today is
just if you are a cat lover there is
something that you can do to help cats
whether that's by adopting from your
local animal shelter or volunteering
whether that's trapping the cats in your
neighborhood for Trap Neuter Return or
whether that is you know getting
involved in fostering fostering is the
greatest way that we can help these
little guys because they are so so at
risk if they don't have our help you
guys but it's amazing what you can do
when you you know change a life by just
giving them you know a little bit of
bottle-feeding a little bit of what you
know bathroom support giving them the
medical help that they need
the great thing about working with an
animal shelter like barks these guys are
from barks animal shelter and falta more
the great thing about working with an
animal shelters they give you all the
support you need so you never have to
feel like you're alone and I want you
guys to know that if you want to help
cats there's a huge community out there
for you and that Inc that community
includes me and my work as kitten lady
it includes this book tiny but mighty it
includes your local animal shelter there
are just so many people in this
community who would love to have you as
part of it so please get active in your
own way let's see some more comments how
do you regulate a kittens body
temperature what a great question that's
awesome
well the way that you work with kittens
and their body temperature is that
kittens up to four weeks old zero to
four week old kittens they can't
regulate the
body temperature it's called thermo
regulation they can't do it without mom
cat to help keep them warm so these
little orphans they always have to have
a heat source at this age you can use a
heat pad like a microwavable heat that
pad or an electric heat pad or you know
if you are in my house we actually have
incubators for the babies and that's
something that can help keep them warm
and help regulate their body temperature
it's really important to know that it's
not safe to care for a kitten if they're
really cold a cold kitten you know they
are not able to suckle as well it can be
really dangerous to feed them so one
essential skill for working with these
little teeny guys is to keep them warm
let's see some more questions and tell
me guys in the comments do you have a
cat at home we're celebrating
international cat day today so you guys
tell me about your cat's in the comment
I would love to know we have a couple
people saying that they are fostering
kittens right now that's awesome let's
see what other questions do you guys
have somebody's asking how many cats do
you have well I have three cats of my
own but I have a revolving door of
foster kittens and that's because my
goal is to save as many lives as I
possibly can while I'm on this earth I'm
and that means that I have a lot of work
to do with these little foster kittens
they come into my house for about eight
weeks I get in the tiniest kittens and
then by the time they're eight weeks old
they're able to be adopted so I'll have
anywhere from five to twelve foster
kittens at a time and then you know they
get healthy get old enough to go to
their new home and they they get adopted
and it's so joyous to watch I hope that
you guys will check out my youtube
channel which is called kitten lady you
can see a lot of fun stories on there
and of course you can read a lot of
stories in the book and hey if there are
any kids or families with kids I also
have a children's book coming out it's
called kitten lady's big book of little
kittens and it is a really really fun
adventure that is you know just teaching
kids all about compassion for these
little kings
but let's get to the most important part
we have to name these kittens you guys
and I need your help
so please we've got two little babies
here and I would love for you to help me
name them so put your best kitten name
ideas in the comments and I am going to
check out what you have to say let's see
and yes happy international cat day you
guys what a great way to celebrate with
these beautiful little babies from barks
Animal Shelter in Baltimore
now no matter where you are there are
kittens like this and they need your
help they need foster homes I'm so let's
see we have bumble and B we have Leah
and Asha toffee oh my gosh you guys have
so many great ideas they're coming so
fast I want to see some great names that
are that are paired names that go
together oh I love storm and cloud
that's beautiful cuz these guys kind of
do look like a little grey storm cloud
oh it's so fun to name kittens you know
I've had to name so many kittens and
it's always a fun thing to do I try to
look at them and figure out what's a
good name for you so um how do we how
are we gonna do this together how do you
guys feel about storm and cloud I love
those names and this one I think looks
like a cloud cuz she almost has a little
cloud right there on her on her head so
maybe for now we'll call you guys storm
and cloud and your names can always
change but thank you to the person who
made that great suggestion I loved that
name it's also perfectly fitting for
nature lovers which of course all of us
are I want to thank National Geographic
for having me here to celebrate
international cat day it's been really
fun hanging out with all of you guys and
with these two especially I hope that
you've learned a little bit about how to
bottle-feed these kittens if there's
more that you want to learn check out my
book tiny but mighty this has everything
you need to
about how to take care of baby kittens
and I'm gonna go snuggle these guys
because you know what it's it's national
international cat day and you guys gotta
love your cats and kiss your cats at
home and thank you so very much for
spending this spending this day with me
here at barks animal shelter with these
little kittens
please get active for cats in your
community and thank you have a wonderful
international cat day you guys
[Music]